Spider-Man is speaking out at D23 Expo 2019.
Things haven't been easy lately for actor
Tom Holland.
He's had one of the worst weeks an actor could
have after the unthinkable happened: news
broke that Disney and Sony failed to renegotiate
their 2015 deal.
That landmark agreement allowed Holland's
Sony-owned Spider-Man to appear in movies
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe, earning
money for Sony while Marvel maintained creative
input.
If a new deal really isn't being negotiated,
it means that Spider-Man is leaving the MCU.
In other words, Holland's world got flipped
upside down.
His future with both Marvel Studios and Sony
Pictures was called into question, and his
millions of adoring fans wondered why he wasn't
speaking out about the situation.
One would imagine that Holland, a longtime
Spider-Man fan, would be devastated over the
Disney-Sony divorce - and apparently, they'd
be mostly right.
Holland finally broke his silence about the
studio split during D23 Expo on Saturday,
August 24.
Taking the stage to promote his upcoming movie
Onward, a Pixar animated flick also featuring
Marvel favorite Chris Pratt, Holland admitted
that he's been having a rough time since the
news dropped, and he's trying to focus on
what matters most.
Though Holland didn't say much about the corporate
spat, the message he did deliver to his fans
was an emotional one:
"It's been a crazy week, but I want you to
know I am grateful from the bottom of my heart,
and I love you 3,000."
"3000, that's crazy.”
The 23-year-old actor's candid admission is
both refreshing and heartbreaking, and his
mention that he's genuinely thankful for his
fans and for the opportunity to play Spider-Man
over the years is enough to make anyone shed
a tear or two.
After the presentation at D23, Holland spoke
with Entertainment Weekly about leaving the
MCU, promising that he'll keep stepping into
the Spidey suit for as long as he can and
continue making the franchise as great as
it can be.
He told the magazine,
"Basically, we've made five great movies.
It's been five amazing years.
I've had the time of my life.
Who knows what the future holds?
But all I know is that I'm going to continue
playing Spider-Man and having the time of
my life.
It's going to be so fun, however we choose
to do it."
He added optimistically,
"The future for Spider-Man will be different,
but it will be equally as awesome and amazing,
and we'll find new ways to make it even cooler."
Marvel Studios president Kevin Feige, who
produced both Homecoming and Far From Home,
also addressed the situation, echoing Holland
with his own optimistic viewpoint.
He said,
"[What] I'm feeling about Spider-Man [is]
gratitude and joy.
We got to make five films within the MCU with
Spider-Man: two standalone films and three
with the Avengers.
It was a dream that I never thought would
happen.
It was never meant to last forever.
We knew there was a finite amount of time
that we'd be able to do this, and we told
the story we wanted to tell, and I'll always
be thankful for that."
Yeah, but tell that to Far From Home's cliffhanger
ending.
In a perfect world, Holland would have never
needed to address the Disney-Sony breakup
because it never would have happened.
If all had gone the way everyone truly wanted
it to go, the two companies would have been
able to reach an agreement to keep Spider-Man
in the MCU.
Far From Home served as the conclusion for
Marvel's Phase 3, and considering how much
emphasis the movie placed on Spider-Man as
a successor to Tony Stark, many were pondering
the character's place in the upcoming Phase
4 and beyond.
A third Spider-Man movie continuing Peter
Parker's story felt inevitable, but now that
the character's connections to the MCU have
apparently been severed, no one knows what
that movie is going to look like.
Before the news broke, it felt like Holland's
Spider-Man was going to avoid the same fate
as Andrew Garfield's iteration of the character,
and would get to complete his trilogy and
then some.
But it looks those assumptions were wrong.
There's no telling what will happen for Holland's
Spider-Man next, but one thing's for sure:
no matter what, fans will be telling the actor
that they love him 3,000 for years to come.
"What am I even tripping for?
Everything's going to work out exactly the
way it's supposed to."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.